My name is Marino Widje. I am a
platform slash developer advocate at Solo. One thing
I will share is that, David, you've been
a fantastic
pillar in our community. You've done so much.
I know it's it's a little bit heartfelt
and emotional, but I will say, like, the
last year, I've been impacted by all the
things you've done, and I've been inspired by
all the things you've done and accomplished,
and it only makes me incrementally better. Right?
It's not the idea of, hey, I need
to take on something else, but to be
a lot more intentional. And I've seen that
through you and in the work that you've
done. And you know what, I wanna kind
of emulate emulate some of that too if
possible. So thank you for all you do.